GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I'M BRET BAIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SPENDING ANOTHER
DAY TRYING TO ADVOCATE FOR
STRICTER GUN LAWS AND TO CLARIFY
HIS POSITIONS ON ONE OF THE MOST
DIVISIVE SUBJECTS FOR BOTH HIS
SUPPORTERS AND CRITICS.
NOT FAR FROM THE WHITE HOUSE,
CONSERVATIVES ARE BEING WARNED
BY THE HEAD OF THE     THE GUN L
BY THE HEAD OF THE     THE GUN B
BY THE HEAD OF THE     THE GUN Y
THAT GUN RIGHTS OPPONENTS ARE
USING THE FLORIDA SCHOOL
MASSACRE TO GO AFTER THEIR
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF WITH
ANOTHER DAY LOOKING FOR ANSWERS.
>> GOOD EVENING.
IT WAS THE SECOND MEETING
PRESIDENT TRUMP CONVENED AT THE
WHITE HOUSE ON THE MARJORY
STONEMAN DOUGLAS SCHOOL
SHOOTING, MEETING WITH STATE AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS TODAY TO HEAR
SUGGESTIONS AND FLOAT A FEW
IDEAS OF HIS OWN.
>> HOW WE CAN MAKE OUR SCHOOLS
SAFER.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP BUILD THE
MEETINGS AS LISTING SESSIONS BUT
ON ONE ISSUE, THE PRESIDENT AND
FAR MORE TALKING THAN LISTENING.
>> WE HAVE TO HARDEN OUR
SCHOOLS, NOT SOFTEN THEM UP.
A GUN FREE ZONE TO A KILLER OR
SOMEBODY THAT WANTS TO BE A
KILLER, THAT'S LIKE GOING IN FOR
THE ICE CREAM.
THAT'S LIKE "HERE I AM.
TAKE ME."
>> CALLING GUN FREE ZONES
NONSENSE, PRESIDENT TRUMP PUSHED
TO TRAIN AND ARM QUALIFIED
TEACHERS TO STAND AS THE
FRONTLINE AGAINST A SCHOOL
SHOOTER.
>> PRACTICALLY FOR FREE YOU HAVE
HOME MADE THE SCHOOL INTO A
HARDENED TARGET.
I THINK WE NEED HARDENED SITES.
WE NEED TO LET PEOPLE KNOW YOU
COME INTO OUR SCHOOLS, YOU'RE
GOING TO BE DEAD.
IT'S GOING TO BE FAST.
UNLESS YOU DO THAT, YOUR POINT
TO ALWAYS HAVE THIS PROBLEM.
>> A HANDFUL OF SCHOOLS HAVE
ADOPTED THE IDEA.
GETTING THAT WIDESPREAD VALUE
NECESSARY TO SERVE AS A NATIONAL
DETERRENT WILL BE A CHALLENGE
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> MUCH OF A REACTION WE HAVE
SEEN HAS BEEN NEGATIVE.
DOES THE PRESIDENT EXPECT HE CAN
GET ENOUGH BUY-IN TO SEND A
SIGNAL TO SHOOTERS THAT IT'S A
HARDENED FACILITY.
YOU WALK IN THE DOOR, YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO LAST VERY LONG.
>> HE THINKS SO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS,
LEADERS IN CONGRESS, THE NRA HAS
BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF THIS IDEA.
A LOT OF OTHER FOLKS HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS IDEA.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP INSISTS HIS
PLAN COULD PUT AN END BACK TO
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS BUT IT WASN'T
HIS ONLY IDEA, TWEETING THIS
MORNING:
"I WILL BE STRONGLY PUSHING
COMPREHENSIVE BACKGROUND CHECKS
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON MENTAL
HEALTH.
RAISE AGE TO 21 AND END SALE OF
BUMP STOCKS!"
RAISING THE AGE PUTS
PRESIDENT TRUMP AT OFFICER AT
THE NRA WHICH FIERCELY OPPOSES
CHANGES.
THE STATEMENT SAYING "PASSING A
LAW THAT MAKES IT ILLEGAL FOR A
20-YEAR-OLD TO PURCHASE A
SHOTGUN FOR HUNTING OR AN ADULT
SINGLE MOTHER FROM PURCHASING
THE MOST EFFECTIVE SELF DEFENSE
RIFLE ON THE MARKET PUNISHES
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS FOR THE
EVIL ACTS OF CRIMINALS."
WHILE THE NRA SAYS THERE'S BEEN
NO CHANGE IN ITS POSITION,
PRESIDENT TRUMP BELIEVES THEY
WILL WORK IT OUT.
>> THE NRA WANTS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
I HAVE SPOKEN TO THEM OFTEN IN
THE LAST TWO DAYS.
THEY WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
THEY ARE GOING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING, I HAVE NO DOUBT.
>> THE DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL
SHOOTING HAS IGNITED PASSIONS
AND THE POLITICAL ARENA.
AND A CNN TOWN HALL, FLORIDA
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO WAS
CONFRONTED BY THE FATHER OF A
YOUNG WOMAN KILLED.
>> YOUR COMMENTS THIS WEEK AND
THOSE OF OUR PRESIDENT HAD BEEN
PATHETICALLY WEAK.
>> ON CAPITOL HILL, GROUP OF
SEVEN DEMOCRAT SENT A LETTER TO
PAUL RYAN ASKING FOR DEBATE TO
REPEAL AN    AND NRA BACKED AMEN
REPEAL AN    AND NRA BACKED AMEE
REPEAL AN    AND NRA BACKED AMED
FROM 1986 THAT PREVENTS THE CDC
FROM DOING RESEARCH INTO GUN
VIOLENCE.
THE FBI WAITED IN.
ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR
RESPONDING TO WHY THE FBI FAILED
TO ACT ON A JANUARY TO ABOUT THE
DOUGLAS SCHOOL SHOOTER.
>> LET ME BE CLEAR.
THERE WAS A MISTAKE MADE.
WE KNOW THAT.
BUT IT'S OUR JOB TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO ENSURE THAT DOES NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN.
I'M NOT MAKING EXCUSES, BECAUSE
WHAT HAPPENED WAS A TRAGEDY,
TRULY A TRAGEDY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SUGGESTED
TODAY CHANGING THE LANGUAGE
AROUND ACTIVE SHOOTER DRILLS AT
SCHOOLS SAYING THEY SHOULD
SIMPLY BE CALLED SAFETY DRILLS
BECAUSE YOUNG STUDENTS
PARTICIPATING IN AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER DRILL COULD BE